- Our next guest is a
platinum selling artist,
whose latest album is called
On Earth and in Heaven.
You can also catch him these days
on The Masked Singer,
returning March 10th on Fox.
Everybody say hello to
my friend, Robin Thicke!
(audience cheering)
It's so nice to see you.
- It's so nice to see you.
How are you?
- I'm so good.
Your hair is a little longer.
I saw you turn to the side
during like the commercial.
Your hair is like a little longer.
- Yeah.
- I like it.
- I'm almost full Swayze at this point.
It's Dirty Dancing Swayze. (chuckles)
- Well, speaking of Swayze,
I feel like you're always smooth.
So like, was there ever
like an awkward phase?
Please say yes.
- Oh yes.
Oh, I've had many, but probably
my most awkward phase was,
you know, when I was about 13 and 14
and I was into everything hip hop.
I wore my overalls backwards
with crossed colors.
I had different color legs and yeah.
So, it was me trying to be as hip hop
and Bell Biv DeVoe as possible
was probably my awkward phase.
- Oh my gosh, Bell Biv DeVoe.
That's an all skate y'all,
a lot of those songs.
Well, you write from life experience.
So, what's an unusual moment
that inspired a song on this album?
- Well, on this album
there was a great moment
where I was jamming with the
band and we were getting,
we're getting ready to go on tour.
And then my beautiful daughter, Lola,
who at the time was just
about one years old.
She came in and we started,
I started singing Lola, Lola, Lola, Lola.
And we ended up with this great
kind of Spanish salsa jam,
you know, to honor my two
daughters, Lola and Mia.
- That's so cool.
I love when random
stuff like that happens.
It's funny how life kind of does that.
- We love in music and in art,
we love those magical mistakes
that you end up keeping,
you know?
- Yeah, absolutely.
So what about, I heard about,
is it the Shooter song?
What's that one?
- Yes.
Well, the Shooter song was
actually on my first album.
When I was around 18 years old
there was a crazy story that took place
where I was in the bank getting some cash
for a weekend vacation
and the bank got robbed.
So, these two guys came in with, you know,
masks, automatic weapons,
and told everyone to
get down on the ground.
And so I ended up writing this whole song
about my experience going
through a live bank robbery.
And then years later,
Little Wayne ended up
doing a verse on it
and put it on his album
and he won a Grammy on
that album actually.
- That's amazing though.
That's an incredible experience.
Somebody told me that
and I was like wait what?
I didn't know that.
- It was pretty wild
- That's traumatizing.
- It was a little traumatizing.
However, I think once it was
over, I was okay with it.
It reminded me of the movies.
It just, it seemed kind
of surreal at the time.
I didn't really feel threatened
as much as I did like,
wow this really does look like a movie.
- Oh my God.
You're different than me.
I'd be in therapy the next morning.
I'd be like, it was tragic.
- Well, you know what it was,
it was probably because
they were very young.
They seemed like they
were 19, 18 year old kids.
They looked just like my
friends dressed up in masks.
You know what I mean?
I didn't see,
so I didn't see these
big muscular adult men.
I saw like two slim teenage men come in
- Making poor decisions.
- And they looked like my buddies.
So, there was something
strange about that,
that probably. (chuckles)
- Yeah, absolutely.
That probably was, yeah, I
guess that was different,
but you have a new album called
On Earth and in Heaven
we were talking about it.
So, what's the inspiration
for this one, man?
- Well, you know, Kelly, the last,
since I saw you last,
it's been a whirlwind.
You know, I had this
blurred lines success,
and then I had, I got divorced
and I, my father passed away.
My beloved father passed away.
My house burnt down.
My manager passed away.
My mentor passed away
last year when COVID hit.
So, I've been through so much loss
and it's been a tough road back,
but I've really learned to take all
that life has thrown at me
and try to turn it into
something beautiful and positive.
I have three new children,
a total of four now that keep me smiling
and working hard every day.
And so this album is a testament
called On Earth and in Heaven
of the people that have
passed and moved on
and the influence that they've had on me
and they still have on me,
even though they're gone.
And the other people
that are here on earth
like my fiance, my
mother, and my four kids
that give me strength and, you know,
make me want to be the
best person I can be.
- Absolutely.
That's a lot of tragedy.
That's a lot of major things happening
and I'm surprised it
wasn't a country album.
Like that was like,
that was the makings of
a great country album.
- Yeah, soul music and country music,
they go hand in hand.
- They're cousins.
I've always said they're
cousins, I believe that.
Well, you're performing for us later.
So, what are you gonna be singing?
- I'll be singing a
song called Lucky Star.
Which is actually the last
song I wrote for the album.
And it's dedicated to my father
and Andre Horrell, who was
my mentor for 20 years,
and executive produced all my albums.
And it's about, we all have
a lucky star in our life
that when we're alone, we
know we're not really alone.
And we talk to that energy
and we pray to that energy
and it helps guide us through
the tough times, you know?
- Oh, that's a beautiful,
beautiful thought.
I love that.
Well, everybody Robin's album is called
On Earth and in Heaven.